harry and dudley are attacked by
dementors to kick off our adventure
since parter uses magic outside of
hogwarts he is almost expelled but the
quiet neighbor lady across private drive
saves the day between this we get
introduced to the super secret order of
the phoenix headquarters now under
umbridge a character arguably worse than
voldemort you deserve to be punished the
golden trio decide to start their own
exclusive group called dumbledore's army
they find a secret room where they
safely practice spells on each other
meanwhile harry takes lessons to control
his connection with voldemort aka snape
torturing harry during this we learned
that james potter was kind of a big
meanie to snake your father was a squad
a bridge catches our heroes in her
office but before she can continue to be
the worst she is carried away by
centaurs harry and friends fly to the
ministry on thestrals where they fight
off death eaters and harry learns about
his prophecy
since cedric's death wasn't enough in
the last film bellatrix kills sirius
right in front of harry's eyes
dumbledore fights voldemort and the rest
of the wizarding world finally accepts
that the dark lord has returned